[Music]
foreign
we do not know why we are here
we do not know who built the silence
and why we are underground
we only know
the world outside our Sanctuary is death
I boil The Pact
and one rule
when I say you want to go
Monica or you will go outside
don't you ever think about the world
Beyond The Silo what if what we see is
not what's out there
got a mechanical there's always someone
who has a theory about the sign up I
need to find out the truth
found something that might have called
the answers to a lot of questions
they quit
and keep your head down
are you willing to give everything you
have for this
[Music]
clock is running
there isn't much time left
this is a threat to order in the silence
I don't care about ordering what about
the truth
all right
some Mysteries
they're best left unsolved
[Music]